lawyers representing the six cancer
patients walk to file their lawsuit at
tokyo district court they say tokyo
electric power company holdings should
pay more than five million dollars in
compensation after their clients were
exposed to radiation following the 2011
nuclear disaster in fukushima
one of the six plaintiffs who doesn't
want to be identified says cancer has
ruined her life
i always wanted to be a career woman
working hard in tokyo but i was
diagnosed with cancer and i still feel
ill after i had surgery since then i'm
in a situation where i have to
prioritize my health over everything
in march 2011 a magnitude 9 earthquake
struck japan's eastern coast it
triggered a tsunami that sent huge waves
surging as far as 10 kilometers inland
the fukushima nuclear power plant was
also overwhelmed and seawater flooded
its reactors
radiation leaked out forcing more than
150 000 people to flee
the six people suing the operator lived
in fukushima in 2011 and later developed
thyroid cancer lawyers say cases of the
disease in fukushima are significantly
higher than the national average
thyroid cancer is a rare disease that
only one in a million people get on
average as the number of children in
fukushima is around 30 000 only one
person would get it every few years
but after the nuclear disaster
266 people have developed cancer in
fukushima
a um report last year found the nuclear
disaster had not increased the risk of
cancer and the authorities in fukushima
say the high detection rate is due to
over-diagnosis
but lawyers say fukushima's owners
should be held accountable for radiation
exposures unless they can prove
otherwise
victoria gatenbee al jazeera